el presidente chileno sebastián piñera
ha podido por fin realizar esa gira
europa que había planificado hace poco
más de un año pero que debió suspender
debido a las críticas por la gestión en
que su gobierno hizo de la crisis del
cobi 19 el presidente francés emmanuel
macro no ha sido el primer mandatario
con el que logra reunirse tras el
encuentro ambos presidentes dieron una
declaración coincidiendo en varios
puntos en que conversaron por ejemplo de
la necesaria modernización del acuerdo
de cooperación entre la unión europea y
chile hablaron también sobre medio
ambiente recordemos que el país
sudamericano presidió la con 25 y ahora
pasa el testigo a escocia concretamente
que va a organizar la cob 26 en glasgow
pero también hablaron sobre la
colaboración en la protección de los
océanos y los bosques y en la lucha
contra el kobe 19 piñera destacó la
rapidez con que la ciencia ha encontrado
una vacuna por su parte macrón felicitó
a chile por el ejemplo democrático que
ha dado al estar redactando una nueva
constitución con una comisión
constituyente paritaria los críticos del
presidente piñera en chile dicen que
este viaje busca internacionalizar este
segundo mandato del presidente sebastián
piñera que justamente quería darle
es más internacional a este segundo
periodo pero que se vio impedido
justamente por el estallido social que
tuvo lugar en el país sudamericano